le chemin le plus court pour savoir ce
qu'il ya dans les produits c'est
finalement nous consommateurs de décider
ce qui est dans chaque produit donc qui
arrive dans les rayons et imaginer créer
choisi au niveau du cahier des charges
par les consommateurs eux mêmes
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les consommateurs ce qu'ils
sont devenus acteurs ce à dire que le
consommateur qui poussait son caddie et
en grande surface en ayant juste comme
information le prix il a plus envie de
ça il veut voir les choses différemment
quand il a compris que quand il a acheté
une brique de lait il participait avec
son argent au fait qu'un autre bout un
producteur ne gagne pas sa vie se sont
posés la question d'essayer de
comprendre ce qui manquait un producteur
sur un litre de lait en a compris 7 et 8
centimes
et puis on s'est dit mais on va les
mettre voilà comment est arrivé le
premier cahier des charges où chaque
critère choisi par les consommateurs
devenait le prix final quand vous donnez
des centimes supplémentaires un
producteur voulu donner aussi les moyens
de vous faire de la qualité c'est à dire
que quand vous compte il est rémunéré au
juste prix il peut sortir ses vaches 3 6
mois au lieu de les garder un peu se
forme aussi d'économie dans les tables
quand vous lui donnez des centimes
supplémentaires il enlève les ogm de
l'alimentation
donc c'est gagnant gagnant
[Musique]
on faisait le témoignage de jean qui est
né 20 centimes par litre et d'un seul
coup qui vous disais moi je me levais
chaque matin non pas pour même pas
gagner d'argent pour en perdre 80 vaches
je peux pas les laisser tomber tous les
matins je m en occuper et à la fin de la
journée j'ai perdu 120 euros et là il
vous envoie une carte en vous disant
j'ai pu pour la première fois prendre
une semaine de vacances ça vous paraît
largement de tous vos efforts